hmm andy you're fine but just simple
okay leslie knope outfit number eight
babe
you look super hot you realize you've
said that about all of them well she has
every single time because she is super
hot honestly
you look hot naked ugh we need to start
teaching women football when teaching
women ufc
teaching them to drive trucks without
crashing hey maybe i'm
only sexy then maybe that's all you see
but at least you can give me extra money
tip money and stuff i'll flirt with you
write my name on a napkin they're gonna
do it
in a right kind of legal way that
empowers prostitution
we don't rest until we get that that
will be progress
that is extremely incorrect i thought i
thought maybe it was
when i was i yep i'll get him next time
back to you professor
god i swear it's almost like they don't
want you to win
well you better practice you gotta win
me a teddy bear
i'm gonna win you a million teddy bears
well i want a billion teddy bears well
that's a little unrealistic
this is a hard game two million that is
the coolest
sentence i've ever heard somebody talk
what's great about you i'm
nice good nice
what else i'm in a band band
what else that's it
i once forgot to brush my teeth for five
weeks i didn't actually sell my last car
i just forgot where i parked it
i don't know who al gore is and at this
point i'm too afraid to ask
when they say two percent milk i don't
know what the other 98
is when i was a baby my head was so big
scientists did experiments on me
i once threw beard a swan and then it
attacked my niece rebecca
oh my god you're not supposed to let me
see you no come on you have to look
this is important you have to tell me if
i look good hey
babe you had a crush on me that's
embarrassing
we're married still hi april
it's me andy just stay sleeping
i am going to be here when you wake up
i will not leave your side
you could be asleep for hours maybe i'll
come back later
hope you feel better okay oh and i know
you think that i'm a jerk
but i hope you can forgive me
gross your forehead is all sweaty that's
gross
i still like you okay
oh that's disgusting is it my turn yes
april you're the most awesome person i
have ever known in my entire life
i vow to protect you from danger
i don't care if i have to fight an
ultimate fighter or a bear
or him your mom i would
take him down andy i'm getting mad right
now even thinking about it i'm telling
you it's okay
hey i love you dude
shut up that is awesome sauce
it's really important to me that april
loves camping so i
went ahead and set up the ultimate
campsite
love nest complete with beautiful
starlight we got champagne
also rose petals as you can see they
smell terrific
where are you i'm here where are you
we're
inside the main entrance near the sign
that says pawnee campground
oh i'm in a totally different place
that's why we can't see each other oh my
god andy i don't even want to be here
the air is too fresh it's disgusting i
can't breathe
there's a brook somewhere that won't
stop babbling shut up
sweetheart just hold tight and uh i'll
be there
well april is right here and i
am down here somewhere i don't want you
to go back to london
just remember every time you look up at
the moon i too
will be looking at a moon not the same
moon obviously that's impossible
april you're like an angel with no wings
so like a person okay
something is different about my computer
aha it's gone oh
a game is the foot see
part of the police academy entrance exam
is investigating a crime
so about a month ago i told everyone in
the office that at some point they
should steal something from my desk so i
could practice
let's do this wait
hey do you guys take my glasses too i
got my sunglasses too
what are you doing when i get bummed out
i take my shirt off because the bad
feelings make me feel sweaty
ah ron and diane sitting in a treat
k-i-s-s-i-s-s-i-p
do you hear that bird what does this do
i uh i wrote you a song score what's it
called
not telling but i'll give you a clue
it's named after a month out of the year
so april no
that would have been way better april is
the best but she's 20.
when april was born i was already in
third grade which means if we were
friends back then i'd have been hanging
out with a baby
i don't know anything about infant care
oh my god i could have killed her messy
is fun
okay my whole life is a giant mess and i
love it
i mean look at my hair i have gum in my
hair when you're in a
situation you don't have time to
think so i thought to myself
don't think andy act so
you weren't thinking not at all
i cannot emphasize enough how little i
was thinking
yo so i feel like you were mad at me
yesterday and i don't know why
so i made a list of everything i did and
i'm gonna try not to do any of them
again
also i got you this coffee
oh baby thank god you're here i got so
bored i started thinking about existence
do i matter do any of us is there a
master plan in the works a grand design
just dumb stuff like that yeah andy come
help me tamp this down
for the last time ron it's princess
rainbow sparkle
uh is there any chance you can fix me in
the next 10 minutes sure
i'll just advance medical science 30
years great
i like you in a
you know romantical kind of way
you do yes do you
like me yes
oh my god are you okay yeah i'm good
check this out i just invented it super
straw
you're never gonna need that computer
again
cause i'm home for like 19 hours i kind
of forgot that you need
money when you have a girlfriend hmm
i want to treat april like a queen and
queens deserve
flowers and massages
chocolate booze diamonds rubies
emeralds them treasure chests full of
scarves
different kinds of lubes that warm up
when you rub them on stuff i'm gonna
give her all that stuff
and more
you